mire esto ha sido realmente un hecho sin
precedentes
estamos ante una insurrección
de militantes fanáticos de trump
insurrección que ha sido promovida es
incitada por el propio trump algo que
jamás ha ocurrido en los eeuu
lo cierto es que
estos vándalos que han logrado incluso
entrar al capitolio en el humillado a
las autoridades incluyendo el propio
vicepresidente que tuvo que salir
corriendo con su equipo de seguridad
para refugiarse fuera del edificio y la
gravedad de ese enorme las consecuencias
para la democracia de los eeuu son
gravísimas son muy serias
estamos ante un fenómeno que ha sido
fabricado por fan él ha perdido en toda
la línea las elecciones las
presidenciales y el resto de las
elecciones tanto en el senado como en la
cámara y sin embargo se rehúsa a aceptar
el resultado y está dispuesto a dañar y
erosionar la democracia y deslegitimar
ante los ojos de millones de americanos
que creen ciegamente entran ante ellos
deslegitimar las instituciones
democráticas simplemente porque él se
resiste a conceder a entender que ha
sido derrotado y que debe salir del
poder y por ello se ha organizado todos
estos eventos toda esta estrategia para
intentar preservar el poder mantenerse
en él incluso una vez que se dé el
cambio de mando a partir del 20 de enero
de este año
es posible calcular las secuelas que
dejará este día como puede eeuu pasar la
página ahora
esto va a ser muy difícil muy muy
difícil
e
para empezar creo que el congreso está
haciendo lo correcto y es el de retomar
y restablecer las sesiones que estaban
programadas lo antes posible creo que
van a empezar a sesionar justamente esta
noche la constitución así lo establece
esta no es cualquier reunión la que se
debe dar el día de hoy presidida por el
vicepresidente pendón es la reunión que
concluye todo el proceso del colegio
electoral y donde se ratifican los
resultados de la elección del país es
muy importante el congreso que los
congresistas demócratas y republicanos
no sugieran que han sido intimidados que
le tienen miedo a estos a estas
pandillas que han operado como unos
verdaderos energúmenos el día de hoy en
washington es muy importante que exista
los grados los niveles de seguridad
necesario que hasta ahora no hay si no
hay no han existido lamentablemente para
hacerle frente a esta situación ahora
serán las secuelas es muy difícil de
predecir todo dependerá de la capacidad
que tenga can más allá del 20 de enero
para mantener esa manipulación esa
relación
tan ciega y enfermiza con sus bases si
esas bases siguen idolatrando a trump
como un semidiós que ha sido despojado
de un triunfo electoral
el restablecimiento de la normalidad
democrática los eeuu va a demorar y
mientras demore hay enormes riesgos de
violencia porque si aquellos millones de
americanos que votaron por camps le
creen
y consideran que han sido robados en su
triunfo electoral en un país como este
donde el acceso a armas y el portar
armas está protegido constitucionalmente
en aquellos partidarios militantes
ciegos de trump
probablemente van a hacer uso de la
violencia seguirán haciéndolo uso la
violencia como lo hicieron el día de hoy
con el propósito de hacer valer su
presencia y defender sus sus sus
intereses sus políticas y la imagen del
funk pero si toman pierde poder y pasa a
ser alguien realmente irrelevante para
la política de los eeuu a partir del 20
de enero que será posible creo que se
puedan restablecer y restablecer la
normalidad y aquellos sectores que se
sintieron liderados por trump entiendan
que han sido engañados como queda la
imagen de la democracia estadounidense
ante la comunidad internacional cuáles
pueden ser las consecuencias de esta
elección para la vista de eeuu en el
mundo
como la imagen que podríamos ver de una
república bananera es decir este
un país que se precia de contar con un
modelo democrático ya operado
intendente al menos impecables por por
por por décadas por siglos
con una
el sistema de pesos y contrapesos con
elecciones periódicas y renovación del
poder
en un congreso y en un poder ejecutivo
que operan conforme a los las enmiendas
constitucionales que hoy que ha sido
dividido la culminación de esta patraña
diseñada y anunciada y dirigida por el
propio trump creo que se ha dañado
profundamente la imagen la credibilidad
del sistema democrático norteamericano y
hay muchos
gobiernos o países donde donde las
autoridades no son democráticas que
probablemente se estarán riendo y
estarán celebrando el que en un país que
se precia de ser democrático y que exige
respeto por normas y valores
democráticos de el resto del mundo
especialmente donde se violan esos
valores y principios democráticos
hoy día te haya dado un espectáculo de
este calibre
creo que la legitimidad la capacidad de
los eeuu por liderar una defensa a la
democracia de los derechos fundamentales
de los hechos humanos las libertades
públicas lamentablemente ha quedado
dañada y será muy difícil restablecer
y consecuencias para la política
internacional señor vivanco esto tendrá
incluso efectos en la diplomacia de la
región nos queda sólo un minutito
disculpe yo creo que sí lamentablemente
pero todo dependerá de cómo el próximo
presidente va a ir él diseña su política
exterior especialmente hacia américa
latina una buena noticia es que el día
de hoy se ha consolidado el triunfo de
los demócratas en el senado que sé que
me quedan apenas unos segundos yo
simplemente quisiera
fortalecer este punto en el sentido de
que
si no tuviera el control del senado y la
disfuncionalidad de lo que es la
administración de el poder los eeuu con
el nuevo gobierno de bailén sería
prácticamente total felizmente con el
control del senado y el control de la
cámara vaivén podrá intentar restablecer
la imagen del país y sobre todo tratar
de llegar a esos sectores que hasta el
día de hoy están enceguecidos con trump
para mostrarles las virtudes que
representa el juego democrático en
cualquier sociedad civilizada